FEMA has already mobilized this morning
to respond to hurricane Irma the agency
has delivered 2.4 million meals and
nearly one and a half million litres of
water to Florida the agency is making
similar preparations in Alabama and
Georgia which are also an earnest pad
FEMA administrative Brock long is with
us from FEMA's National Response
Coordination Center in Washington good
morning hey good morning how are you
thank you for doing this this morning
look at this damage so far and put it in
terms of how devastation how bad is the
devastation as you see it and how it
might have been much worse give us the
context yep so clearly the events not
over in some cases the backside of the
storm the the east side of the storm is
pushing water into parts of Jacksonville
Florida and up the coast of Georgia and
South Carolina today we're also
anticipating a lot of inland rainfall in
Georgia so the events not over but
overnight as we you know work with our
state local partners to conduct impact
assessments obviously Monroe County and
the Keys Carter County took the brunt of
the hit with uh with the storm surge
that was there how many people do you
have shelter in shelters in the state of
Florida the last I checked it was well
over two hundred thousand it's hard for
me to keep up with all the numbers right
now because it's a moving target but it
was over two hundred thousand I believe
we near we have nearly nearly 6 million
without power as we anticipated so it's
going to be a long frustrating event for
her Floridians I know everybody needs to
pack their patience Brock with these
back-to-back disasters first Harvey now
Irma and now Jose waiting on deck how
much is it straining your financial and
your physical resources of your team so
regarding the finances the communication
lines with the Congress the White House
and Homeland Security are strong and
they're they're gonna continue to give
us the inter enduring Authority to push
forward on on the money front regarding
staffing and resources obviously two big
events like this staffs the you know
staff staffing resources are strained
but we have great contingency plans in
place with our Department of Defense
friends and you know will stand by me
to support other disasters as they come
and and while we're focused on Florida
let's don't forget our friends in the
Virgin Islands in Puerto Rico as well so
we're still you know managing some
complex missions out there as well you
had a teleconference I think with the
president the vice president other
officials is it fair to say that the
federal government is standing by to do
what is necessary absolutely the
President and the Vice President have
been fully engaged the vice president
spent nearly two hours with us yesterday
here at the National Response
Coordination Center I'll be briefing the
president directly
a little later this morning and we're in
great communication with Governor Scott
I talked to him probably twice daily
just to make sure we understand his
operational priorities and how best to
support them can you put a price tag on
this how much is it gonna cost yeah not
yet not yet
it's really hard to do and and the way
that this works is that we'll be
granting money to help you know help
Florida and other states recover for for
many years you know it's it's it's not
only just the response money but you
know assistance for FEMA will come in
the in the form of post disaster
mitigation funding as well to hopefully
not rebuild to the same standard but to
harden facilities and become more
resilient so that you know what was
knocked out this time has not knocked
out next time administrator I was
interested to know that FEMA has also
started a rumor control website to
combat misinformation and scams
spreading about FEMA in other words like
that floodwaters can spread plague how
important is that to get the right
information out well you know what I
would encourage citizens is to first
listen to their local officials for the
most accurate news again FEMA is not a
first responder you know our role is to
support state and local partners and
it's important for us to build a clear
and consistent message with those
partners all the way through so we have
multiple conversations a day trying to
identify what rumors may exist and then
how to combat them and put them out but
go ahead well this is the thing about
you Brock I really enjoy watching
interviews with you because you were
always seemingly so confident so calm
and so very much in control so what
concerns you most as you sit here
battling two hurricanes and another one
on deck
well it's a tough question because I
really think that we have a long way to
go to create a true culture of
preparedness within our citizenry in
America and no American no citizen no
visitor to this country is immune to
disaster and we have a long way to go to
get people to understand the hazards
based on where they dwell where they
work and how to be prepared financially
how to be prepared through insurance how
to have continuity of operations plans
for their businesses so that we can
avoid the suffering and strife in the
loss of life it's it's truly
disappointing that people won't heed the
warnings yeah administrator you know we
were talking here about what we've just
witnessed because two category four
storms in the same year
apparently unprecedented the size of
these how much does climate change play
a role in these natural disasters well
regardless of what causes the increase
in disasters I have to be prepared to
handle the consequence management of it
and and I think that if we look back I
mean I was very open I knew coming into
this job that the statistics and
probability of being hit by a major
hurricane were against us the last time
we had been hit was 2005 by Wilma in
South Florida and I was addressing to
the staff listen I know coming into this
job we are going to be hit by major
hurricanes it was a like a 1 in 2000's
the chance that we actually went 11
years without a major hurricane so we
have to be ready and the problem is is
that we continue to build build in
vulnerable areas we lack building codes
we lack you know we continue to you know
be our own worst enemy in some cases
thank you for taking time to talk to us
thank you
alright Brock long always in control
thanks a lot